debatte um billigfleisch
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin klöckner
will die branche umkrempeln urlaub in
corona zeiten zum ferienbeginn rechnen
nord und ostsee mit einem
besucheransturm zu jung fürs
geschichtsbuch trainer jürgen klopp
machte liverpool nach 30 jahren wieder
zum meister
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster jan dazu gleich mehr im
sport mit norbert lehmann in einer guten
viertelstunde seien willkommen bei den
nachrichten am freitag
das ist mit unseren fleischkonsum in der
masse und zu den bedingungen für mensch
und tier so nicht weitergehen kann ist
eigentlich schon lange klar
nun bringt auch
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin klöckner
im gespräch mit der fleischbranche auf
veränderungen vor allem was den
wettbewerb mit lockangeboten betrifft
denn die billigprodukte haben ihren
preis keine artgerechte haltung tiere in
massen fabrikation auch die arbeits und
wohnsituation für beschäftigte stehen in
der kritik die forderung verbesserungen
etwa durch höhere löhne und eine
tierwohl abgabe dominik müller rosell
berichtet will ich schnell und so viel
wie möglich so produzieren die
allermeisten fleisch betriebe in
deutschland kaum rücksicht auf arbeiter
oder tirol beim treffen der
fleischbranche mit der politik macht die
landwirtschaftsministerin deutlich wie
dringend sich vieles ändern muss allen
ist klar heute in diesem gespräch
es wird keine zweite chance gibt für die
gesamte branche nicht nur wegen der
aufmerksamkeit sondern weil corona ein
brennglas ist für das was wir erlebt
haben
die umstrittenen gasverträge für
leiharbeiter will die regierung
verbieten beim treffen heute stand das
tier wohl im mittelpunkt fleisch muss
teurer werden so der entschluss der drei
heute beteiligten agrarministerin
deswegen sind wir drei fest davon
überzeugt dass wir an einer tierwohl
abgabe tierwohl umlage wie wir sie
letztlich auch nennen wollen nicht
vorbei kommt das war heute ein für mich
sehr wichtiges ergebnis denn ich bin
fest davon überzeugt nur so gelingt es
uns alle mit in die pflicht zu nehmen
40 cent pro kilo könnte fleisch teurer
werden mit dem geld sollen landwirte
dann etwa ihre stelle tiergerechte
ausbauen können und mehr platz schaffen
höhere preise und dann erst verbesserung
tier und verbraucherschützer kritisieren
die pläne
vielmehr müsste die
landwirtschaftsministerin für
transparenz und klare gesetzliche regeln
sorgen sie fängt an dem die kunden zu
dissen ja ihr müsst mehr bezahlen aber
eigentlich muss doch der hersteller als
erstes sagen dieses ist mein neuer
standard und davon musst du mehr zahlen
und wir machen eine kennzeichnung so
dass du immer weiß wie der standard ist
man sich konkret etwas ändert ist noch
unklar
von einem jahrelangen prozess sprach die
ministerin heute im september will sich
die runde erneut treffen
die erwartungen sind hoch das geschäft
mit dem fleisch ist für die großen
schlachtbetriebe bislang sehr lukrativ
im vergangenen jahr wurden in
deutschland 8,6 millionen tonnen fleisch
produziert knapp die hälfte davon
nämlich 4,1 millionen tonnen gehen
allerdings ins ausland beim
schweinefleisch ist deutschland nach
spanien und den usa sogar weltweit
drittgrößter exporteur elisabeth schmidt
berichtet bei danish crown im
niedersächsischen essen werden jede
woche 64.000 schweine geschlachtet die
hälfte der belegschaft hat werkverträge
mindestlohn 9 eur 35 die stunde in
dänemark mutterland des unternehmens
alle direkt angestellt 25 euro die
stunde minuten deutschland billig
schlacht land für ausländische
unternehmen attraktiv bislang wenn man
ein arbeitnehmer voll und dauerhaft
beschäftigt dann muss man ihn auch
beschäftigen wenn man keine arbeit hat
das wird die preise am ende erhöhen oder
die gewinnmargen der unternehmen
verringern
für den deutschen export schlager
schwein könnte das zum problem werden
auf dem weltmarkt bestehen heißt
massenproduktion möglichst billig 24
millionen tonnen schweinefleisch gehen
jedes jahr ins ausland die hälfte der
produktion höhere löhne mehr tierwohl
das würde einen umbruch für die branche
bedeuten
von den schlachthöfen vermute ich dass
einige aufgeben werden weil sie nicht
mehr rentabel unter ihren vermarktungs
bedingungen also in mengen etwas
absetzen
das umsetzen kann und manche sprechen ja
auch davon dass sie das die schlachthöfe
dann verlagert werden zum beispiel nach
polen
der druck auf die fleisch barone kommt
auch von den kunden laut zdf
politbarometer sind 92 prozent für
schärfere gesetze
um arbeitsbedingungen in
schlachtbetrieben zu verbessern selbst
wenn fleisch dann teurer wird wenn sich
das alles ändern würde dann würden wir
schon 20 prozent mehr dafür bezahlen pro
kilo
wie jetzt gerade im sommer grillen
sowieso fast jeden tag und aber trotzdem
ist es kein problem mehr zu bezahlen
die politik will ist die verbraucher
sind bereit die preise für fleisch in
deutschland werden steigend daran führt
wohl kein weg vorbei die korona
ausbrüche in schlachthöfen haben diese
woche die zahl der neu infizierten in
deutschland in die höhe getrieben jetzt
gehen sie wieder zurück im durchschnitt
der letzten sieben tage haben sich
täglich 510 menschen neu mit corona
angesteckt gestern waren es im schnitt
noch 670 gütersloh und warendorf beide
kreise sind am meisten betroffen vom
neuen virus ausbruch in ostwestfalen
jetzt hat bundesgesundheitsminister
sparen davor gewarnt menschen aus der
region zu diskriminieren manche seien
beschimpft und ihre autos zerkratzt
worden sagte sparen den zeitungen der
funke mediengruppe diese art von
stigmatisierung sei falsch das virus
könne jeden jederzeit erwischen
und weil das so ist beschäftigt die
korona krise nach wie vor politik und
öffentlichkeit immens ein gradmesser
dafür ist das politbarometer das uns
matthias fornoff mitgebracht hat halo
matti also genommen bis jetzt waren die
bundesbürger und bürgerinnen ja mit den
politischen maßnahmen sehr einverstanden
bleibt dass dennoch so die meisten
deutschen haben schon den eindruck dass
die richtung im großen ganzen stimmt
deshalb sagt eine mehrheit von 56
prozent
die lockerungen der letzten wochen sind
richtig aber fast jeder dritte fürchtet
das war schon zu viel
bestätigt fühlen können sich die
skeptiker durch den rasanten anstieg der
infektionsfälle in der region gütersloh
das darauf mit massiven einschränkungen
des öffentlichen lebens reagiert wurde
finden 89 prozent richtig nur neun
prozent falsch die politische stimmung
im land ist derzeit ziemlich stabil
wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre käme
die union auf 40 prozent ihr bestes
ergebnis seit august 2017
zum regieren würde es reichen für
schwarz grün aber auch für schwarz rot
interessante alternative nun hat es ja
unlängst diesen gewaltausbruch in
stuttgart gegeben wo junge männer die
polizei massiv angegriffen haben was hat
es in der bevölkerung ausgelöst naja
wenn polizistinnen oder polizisten
angefeindet oder gar angegriffen werden
dann macht das einer großen mehrheit von
83 prozent der befragten schon sorgen 17
prozent eher nicht
interessant dabei dass die polizei in
deutschland grundsätzlich positiv
gesehen wird
86 prozent geben an dass sie großes oder
sogar sehr großes vertrauen in die
polizei haben und das ist ein
herausragender wert und sicher auch eine
ermutigung vielen dank dafür
ja und das ganze politbarometer alle
zahlen gibt es heute abend im
heute-journal und natürlich finden sie
alle grafiken jederzeit auch online in
unserer zdf heute app vor allem zwei
themen treiben derzeit die afg um die
parteispendenaffäre des vorsitzenden
jörg leuten und der streit um den
brandenburger fraktionschef andreas
kalbitz ist er nun noch parteimitglied
oder nicht beim treffen heute im
thüringischen suhl viel zumindest in
sachen parteispende eine entscheidung
die die afg akzeptiert die geforderte
strafzahlung unklar dagegen wie es in
der personalie kalbitz weitergeht
melanie haack und florian coach andreas
kalbitz kommt zur bundesvorstandssitzung
und mit ihm das problem dass die afg
massiv spaltet darf der rechtsaußen noch
parteimitglied sein oder nicht gutes und
juristisch auch verbrieftes recht meine
ämter wahrzunehmen
ich werde schlecht das mitglied des
bundesvorstandes und geschlechter
landesvorsitzender wenn ich nicht
arbeiten würde für diese partei seinen
rauswurf hat parteichef j9 im mai mit
knapper mehrheit organisiert kalbitz
stellte eilanträge wollte wieder rein
letzte woche gab ihm das berliner
landgericht recht diese woche aber
entschied das parteischiedsgericht zum
eilantrag offenbar doch wieder raus eine
entscheidung die hier noch nicht
vorliegt über die doch alle
neben ich hätte es für stilvolle
gehalten um das so zu sagen wenn er
gesagt hätte wir haben hier ein
schwebendes verfahren und solange lasse
ich ruhe aber in dem kein recht in
anspruch und das habe ich zu
respektieren und das tue ich auch ich
kann einfach nur über diese ganze
juristische angelegenheit und das tut
sie wirklich nur staunen im
hauptsacheverfahren entscheidet das
parteischiedsgericht wohl ende juli und
dann ist da noch der streit über
unerlaubte parteispenden um afg chef
jörg mieten
heute hat der vorstand beschlossen die
strafzahlung in höhe von knapp 270.000
euro zu akzeptieren
damit entgeht leuten einem weiteren
juristischen tauziehen dass er wohl eher
nicht gewinnen kann
angetreten sich ums land zu kümmern
beschäftigt sich die afg momentan fast
nur mit sich selbst
die grünen haben den entwurf für ein
neues grundsatzprogramm vorgestellt und
darin einen führungsanspruch als große
volkspartei formuliert neben den
traditionellen grünen themen wie
klimaschutz und sozialpolitik wolle man
auch in den anderen themenbereichen den
kurs mitbestimmen von bildung über
sicherheit bis zu gesundheit
man sei offen für neue politische
bündnisse erklärten die vorsitzenden
baerbock und harbeck im herbst soll das
programm auf einem parteitag beschlossen
werden
die kirchen in deutschland verlieren
nach und nach ihre gläubigen dieser
trend zeigt sich schon seit einigen
jahren doch noch nie sind so viele
menschen ausgetreten wie 2009 10 etwa
270.000 menschen verließen die
evangelische kirche mehr als 200 72.000
die katholische
damit gehört nur noch etwas mehr als die
hälfte der deutschen einer der beiden
großen konfessionen an
auch bei taufen gehen die zahlen
insgesamt immer weiter zurück wieder
erschüttert ein messerangriff
großbritannien im schottischen glasgow
hat einen mann in einem hotel mindestens
sechs menschen verletzt unter ihnen ist
auch ein polizist
die polizei stürmte das gebäude und
erschoss den verdächtigen sie geht
derzeit nicht von einem terrorangriff
aus
erst am samstag hatte ein mann drei
menschen in der stadt redding mit einem
messer getötet
dort vermuten die ermittler allerdings
terror als motiv corona und
drogenmissbrauch die vereinten nationen
sehen da einen besorgniserregenden
zusammenhang das virus mache einsam
manche auch arbeitslos die sorgen nehmen
zu und damit auch der drogenkonsum
weltweit belastbare zahlen dazu gibt es
noch nicht aber doch die erfahrungen
etwa von betroffenen auf entzug
die in corona zeiten plötzlich alleine
klarkommen müssen 27 berichtet
wir treffen andré in tübingen mit
marihuana hat alles angefangen erzählt
er
dann kam ecstasy später kokain er hat
sich für eine suchttherapie entschieden
reha von morgens bis abends dann kam
corona wochenlang hatte er nur
telefonischen kontakt zu seinen
therapeuten
manchmal kommen dann halt auch die
sachen einfach hoch was alles passiert
ist und natürlich hat das kokain damals
geholfen
sie sagten die probleme wegzudrücken und
durch die phase von corona hat natürlich
auch wieder den kopf voll auch die
drogenberatungsstelle in tübingen war
über wochen nur telefonisch erreichbar
und diese hilfe war dringend nötig bei
corona die drogenproblematik verschärft
hat menschen haben dann hier drogen sich
besorgt über dot net internet irgendwie
die normalen versorgungswege waren
abgeschnitten auch durch die
grenzschließung und alles und die haben
sich dann alles besorgt was man
irgendwie besorgen können
den kontakt zu betroffenen nicht
verlieren das hat auch anil batra
versucht er leitet die sektion
suchtmedizin an der uni klinik in
tübingen und sieht wegen der kontakt
beschränkungen einen gefährlichen trend
wir beobachten insgesamt im suchtbereich
dass es mehrere fälle gegeben hat dass
mehr krisenhafte zuspitzung gegeben hat
und damit auch eine verschlechterung
unter körperlichen und gesundheitlichen
situation unserer klienten zurück in der
tages- reha andrä hat seine therapie
heute abgeschlossen nach 20 wochen er
hat es geschafft ohne rückfall
in vielen bundesländern heißt es derzeit
ab in den urlaub allerdings wird der bei
vielen ganz anders sein als sonst wegen
der virus krise musste umgeplant werden
in berlin brandenburg hamburg und
mecklenburg vorpommern haben die
sommerferien schon begonnen ab montag
kommen schleswig holstein und nordrhein
westfalen dazu viele zieht es an nord
und ostsee aber viele bleiben auch zu
hause und setzen auf tagesausflüge die
straßen könnten also ziemlich voll
werden
peter böhme mit dem auto in den urlaub
schon heute lange staus etwa auf der a 1
richtung ostsee wer auf weit entfernte
ziele verzichten will findet auch in
deutschland seinen spaß wie hier in
düsseldorf auf dem messegelände
da startet heute mittag eine eigentlich
kirmes und doch auch wieder nicht
freizeitpark nennen sie hier
das opulente geschehen kirmes und
großveranstaltungen sind verboten
freizeitparks dürfen unter besonderen
auflagen wieder öffnen und dann nutzen
wir so ein wenig die lücke im gesetz
die messe darf nicht ausstellen und
hardplatz da fanden sich schausteller
zusammen und bieten nun vier wochen
dauer vergnügen corona korrekt etwa mit
einbahnstraßensystem und jeder menge
desinfektion und für manchen ist klar
die flugreise findet in diesem jahr in
düsseldorf statt und auch für viele
schüler werden die ferien anders als
geplant letzter schultag einer siebten
klasse
[Musik]
und jetzt werden wir vielleicht halt an
den wochenenden mal nach holland belgien
so kleine ausflüge dort in domburg in
holland war heute noch platz für diese
touristen aus dem saarland kam auch
nichts anderes in frage wenn man jetzt
mallorca gebucht hätte man das hätten
wir wahrscheinlich abgesagt
da wären wir nicht da war hier jetzt wir
sind aus dem saarland und da war die
anreise recht angenehm mit dem auto
halten und hier sind alle touristen
erwünscht auch die aus gütersloh oder
warendorf die menschen aus
nordrhein-westfalen können gerne kommen
bei der man beschwerden hat dann bleibt
zu hause wenn ihr der sache nicht traut
lasst euch testen urlaub trotz corona
auf jeden fall möglich tja und nun zu
dir norbert und da ist jürgen klopp mit
seinem fc liverpool auf dem besten weg
zur englischen legendäre allerdings und
er ist ja auch der erste deutsche
trainer der mutterland des fußballs den
meistertitel holt und das sieben spiele
vor saisonende und mit 23 punkten
vorsprung 30 jahre ohne meistertitel so
was brauchte einfach ein ventil
der platz vor dem stadion an der anfield
road eine rot-weiße jubel reagiert
abstand halten illusorisch der appell
von jürgen klopp zu hause zu feiern
nur wenige beherzigten ihn als dann
chelsea das 2 2 1 gegen mancity erzielte
erstaunte die wucht des glücksgefühls
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass sich so
große anfühlt wenn es wenn es eintritt
aber es ist wir haben soll ich habe noch
keine dreißig jahren gebar sind aber
alle ahnten und mehr oder weniger und
das sagen wir schon auch gespürt wie in
einem golfclub hatte das thema auf
klopps wunsch hin gemeinsam das spiel
des rivalen erlebt
normalerweise hätte ich spiele auch eine
gestern abend eine kleine ansprache an
die spieler gehalten darüber absolut
nicht möglich sobald ich bestimmte dinge
angesprochen haben selbst wenn ich
darüber nachgedacht habe ich angefangen
zu lernen
viereinhalb jahre club in liverpool sein
optimismus hat alle mitgerissen in der
stadt ist er allgegenwärtig macht ihn
punkto popularität den berühmtesten
söhne der stadt konkurrenz clubs so
etwas wie der fünfte beatle nichts
scheint mit ihm unmöglich
und mehr zum erfolgstrainer jürgen klopp
und dem fc liverpool bei uns in der zdf
mediathek mit zwei wirklich sehr
sehenswerten dokumentation
ja und jetzt von der englischen spitze
zum deutschen tabellenkeller morgen
letzte bundesliga spieltag die
entscheidung wird bremen oder düsseldorf
zweiter absteiger
die fortuna hat zwei punkte vorsprung
werder braucht also unbedingt einen sieg
unterschiedlicher könnten sie nicht
sagen
die gemütslagen die sich in den letzten
wochen aufgebaut haben das momentum es
ist auf seiten der fortuna und das glas
das berühmte wir sind voller optimismus
und klaas ist definitiv halb voll
so gesehen ist das der bremer halbleer
nach der frustration in mainz aber es
ist schwer aber es ist nicht
aussichtslos und wir reden hier nicht
von einer rein theoretischen chance
sondern wir sind auch etwas angewiesen
das ist nicht gut in die situation haben
wir uns gebracht wir kein anderer
wir spielen bisher und das wird sich
auch nicht mehr ändern egal was morgen
passiert eine richtig schlechte saison
wer das problem zudem selbst wenn
fortuna verlöre bei union müsste bremen
gewinnen allerdings liegt das letzte
bremer tor im weser-stadion 4 120
spielminuten zurück wahrlich geisterhaft
und erschreckend es drohte erste werder
abstieg seit 40 jahren
der deutsche wetterdienst warnt aktuell
vor schweren gewittern im südwesten vor
allem in der gegend um aachen und worms
wie sich die gewitter lage heute nacht
und morgen weiter entwickelt dazu gleich
mehr von katja honnefer so viel von uns
danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
christian sieh was erwartet sie mit dem
heute journal um 10 und wir sind morgen
abend wieder für sie da punkt 7 ein
unwetter freien abend wünschen burgess
[Musik]
genannt meine damen und herren gewittrig
klingt diese woche aus zum einen hier im
nordosten der zogen gewitter von polen
herein und zum anderen von südwesten
hier von frankreich von luxemburg und
belgien entwickelten sich am nachmittag
kräftige gewitter und auch in der nacht
haben wir als erster mit gewittern zu
tun die lassen danach erst in der
zweiten nachthälfte überqueren dann
nordrhein westfalen wieder gewitter von
all diesen gewittern bekommen sie
allerdings in einem streifen gar nichts
mit und dieser streifen der liegt
zwischen dem erzgebirge und sylt die
temperaturen dazu sinken im osten auf
immerhin relativ kühle 16 bis 12 grad im
westen bleibt es sehr viel milder mit 9
10 bis 16 grad und morgen hält sich noch
ein rest dieser schwur feuchten gewitter
luft hier im nordosten mit 30 bis 32
grad und auch sonst ist es immer noch
dampf ich auch wenn die temperaturen nur
noch bei 24 bis 29 grad gegen und morgen
ziehen weitere schauer und gewitter über
uns hinweg die erreichen bis zum abend
dann auch die ostsee den harz und
niederbayern das können unwetter seien
gewitter also die mit hagel platzregen
und sturmböen verbunden sind und am
freundlichsten ist morgen vormittag noch
hier im nordosten am sonntag überquert
uns eine kaltfront dann ist es im westen
deutlich frischer bei nur noch 20 bis 22
grad
schönen abend noch